pop
[Musique]
c'est en alsace bien sûr que nous sommes
allés recueillir la recette de la
choucroute dans un village qui s'appelle
rouffach et qui est située à quelques
kilomètres au sud de colmar sur la route
des vins d'alsace pour nous guider
monsieur murray un vigneron de rouffach
qui aime autant son pays que la
choucroute
alors donc quand le choix arrive ouais
mais le traitement qu'on ait fait c'est
bien sûr qui sont en trop hinse qui sont
encore un peu vert après coop quand on a
rangé les feuilles on sort bleus
comme on vous dit le trognon le trognon
césar est au plus haut voyez la
structure avec un couteau qu'on casse
comme ça zf et écoutons et on coupe
ce jour on peut et on donne à matane bat
pour le rap et voilà vous lever et on
obtient ce
ce chou en fait ce jour après qu'on peut
mieux manger c'est bon comme ça déjà
bon mais qui sera encore meilleur joueur
comme ça on lève la pompe ou tes salades
et réponse est donc alors en tête et un
chou donc tombe dans ce tonneau et alors
on fait une certaine couche comme ça et
après medicine couche décès et on est tu
as évadant de trois semaines jusqu'à la
fermentation biologique est terminée
c'est à dire la fermentation n'est
jamais terminé
c'est ça m'a presque toute l'année au
fût rien de sûr c'est pour ça qu'une
chose clochait
mais pas si panju cloud qui a déjà trois
mois on va les voir maintenant comment
comment on la prépare alors cette
choucroute une fois qu'elle est à sa
passion ça c'est une chance pour les
téléspectateurs et pour tout le monde et
marque alors comment qu'on prépare une
vraie choucroute sittomat maintenant on
a vu la fabrication sidati la transforme
après l'astronomie alors allons
rejoindre madame murray et vous allez
constater que contrairement à ce qu'on
pense souvent la choucroute est une
recette relativement facile à réaliser
à muret alors merci d'abord d'avoir bien
voulu nous montrer comment on fait là un
vrai show coude en alsace
oui et en particulier dans la famille
murray très bien puisque c'est une
recette que vous tenez ma mère de vote
alors comment procède-t-on eh bien il
faut pour 6 personnes 1 kg et demi de
choucroute jeu la goutte pour voir quel
est son degré d'acidité
ça va elle n'est pas très acide je vais
lalabé rapidement le laverait combien de
fois suffit si elle n'est pas prise
acide que ça mais on va être amené à
laver plus souvent ah oui si c'est de la
choucroute qui avait déjà mois ou 10
mois dans le tonnelet parce que c'est
les vieilles elle est déjà très acide
on aurait voulu quitter dos voilà la
salle est là mais c'est ça ça suffit
voilà maintenant les pommes de terre
pour messi personnes j'ai un kilo de
pommes de terre c'est-à-dire environ 2
pommes de terre moyenne par personne
ensuite il faut prendre du saindoux mais
ce qui est encore mieux c'est de la
grèce doit alors là j'ai de la chance
d'avoir la graisse d'oie
je vais la mettre dans ma coach alors je
vais couper mon oignon 1 oignon et de
broussailles
voilà
tout parti
la lazio
oui nous aurions dedans avec line alors
pendant que maisonnial blond disent je
vais avoir le temps de couper mon la
géla un morceau de 600 grammes
je coupe trois tranches de 2 cm
d'épaisseur
chacun va donc une demi tranche
oui c'est ça monsieur pierre on va pas
leur donner une tranche entière cela je
vais les poules posé au fond de la
cocotte
j'ai aussi une palette 10 une demie
palette elle pèse un kilo celle là je la
trempe dans mon eau bouillante ou je lis
aussi un oignon une feuille de laurier 1
poireau une feuille de chou voilà et
ceci à le laisser bouillir pendant une
heure et demie alors je continue ce
temps là oui alors je prends la moitié
de la choucroute
cela pose sur mes tranches de lard les
épices
alors la moitié des grandes genièvre
donc j'en mets un peu près 8
de croo shiro fait une pincée de cumin
bonne pincée de cumin une demi cuillère
de sel un peu de poires une feuille de
laurier et voilà aujourd'hui on a donc
fait de la palette sinal pas eu de
paraître j'aurais mis des tranches de
fumée au milieu de la choucroute
vous pouvez prendre du collet fumé ou
bien du filet ou bien de côtelettes
fumée alors vous faites vos huit
tranches voulait poser au milieu la
choucroute mais de vertolaye s'il vous
plaît je suppose encore une fois c'est
du riesling à huy ah oui je coûtais
résine ça se marie bien encore de l'eau
il y à la valeur de 5 verres voilà on
arrose largement moins bien
le reste de la choucroute par dessus
et on finit en mettant le reste des
ingrédients de genièvre de l'aude giraud
pleut une bonne pincée de plus humain
l'autre demi cuillère de stèles un peu
de poivre puis une petite feuille de
laurier par dessus voilà jean taris avec
des pommes de terre couvercle dessus
merci mr et voilà on fait cuire tout ça
là j'ai donc une cocotte
il faut quand la cuisson commence
compter trois quarts d'heure de cuisson
si vous avez un autocuiseur oui je vous
conseille vivement lusage de
l'autocuiseur en inox il vous plaît pour
la choucroute à cause de l'acidité
mais avec l'autocuiseur vous faites
beaucoup plus rapidement on n'a qu'à
venir la choucroute et cuite elle est
aussi bonne
ah oui absolument mais alors le mettais
moins d'eau parce qu'il ya moins de
vapeur qui s'échappe
vous mettrez vos deux verres de vin et
seulement 1 verdon
eh bien vous savez donc que je vais la
garnir avec des tranches de palettes
mais on va encore ajouter des saucisses
alors j'ai là trois sortes saucisses
j'ai les saucisses de montbéliard l'eau
et frémissante jeu les plombs dans cette
eau qui bout légèrement et je vais les
laisser frémir pendant un quart d'heure
ça suffira
tandis que là les saucisses de
strasbourg et les saucisses blanches
on va simplement les mettre dans le lot
très chaude et on va les laisser
réchauffer jusqu'à ce que lâche au
crotoy points qu'est ce que c'est que de
plaisir ça d'une cuisinière assez d'une
cuisinière à bois
c'est l'ancien système on voit pas des
flammes mais à l'intérieur ça chauffe un
abri
il y a dix minutes que mes saucisses
blanches chauffe dans cette eau je vais
donc les sortir pour les essuyer avant
de les griller recourbé saucisse blanche
avec du veau et du port de viande
blanche
combien blanche exact pour commander le
ça nous vaut un bon vous savez là avec
la choucroute on a toujours du sein nous
joe kodeih pour voilà il faut rester
dans la même note s'écriait un peu alors
maintenant les saucisses blanches sont
dorés et s'avoue d'aiguilhe maintenant
la garnir le plat je vais sortir des
pommes de terre on place la choucroute
au milieu du plat et on garnit
strasbourg
au fond du plat à emporter morceau de
lard de la condamner dire en même temps
que la choucroute s ah oui et puis bien
leur pas l'être sarah meier les pommes
de terre autour mais on avoue garder
c'est le plat les l'achat qui disent que
votre refroidir ap
il faut qu'on mette se plaint au chaud
ah bon il faut que la choucroute y mange
très chaud donc on va la mettre au chaud
quelques minutes
oui mais on va la mettre sur le fourneau
et puis comment que ça c'est bien au
chaud nous reste un peu triché pour
déguster cette choucroute
authentiquement alsacienne mal à muret
vous avez installé dans un décor qui est
typiquement alsacien est rien c'est une
des salles à manger je crois de deblé
soir paul bert rue ça c'est étonnant de
trouver une salle à manger avec le lit à
côté de la table
à cela se faisait autrefois oui les
parents dormaient dans ce lit j'ai fermé
les rideaux
vous voyez ce lié à un plafond on
appelle ça un lit à ciel via bâle
d'accueil à baldaquin en france
et si c'était bien au chaud il avait le
bon point de faïence bois de faïence
c'est vrai oui et on allait directement
du lit à table la table au lit bon bah
nous on va aller du lit à la table cette
fois c'est que j'ai l'impression que les
odeurs de choucroute nous arrive de
l'accusé c'est très très bref la
choucroute est prête il faut que j'aille
rocard et bien non il faut absolument
boire du vin d'alsace avec la choucroute
monsieur voiliers mais c'est bien
content et site où la digestion vous
savez la chaux gauthey la poussière en
alsace à quelques kilomètres le long des
bauges pousse le riesling
mais oui mais y en a quand même beaucoup
du move qui mangera jeu coûte avec la
bière oui mais ça et poté les gens qui
sont de france f1
distingué élégant déguster vers demain
avec la choucroute à vous on raconte une
vieille histoire
il y avait une ménagère très près serre
était un peu en retard pour aller à la
messe alors elle avait préparé sur la
table son livre de messe et le morceau
de lard à l'eau dans sa précipitation
elle prend le livre de maistre defour
dans la foule et prend le large
[Musique]